micheline format sata iii of the
development of consultation ouidah uk
tomorrow we are going to translate the
political commitments made together
with the united kingdom in december into a
legal text the text that I will
present tomorrow will also contain our
positions on the other subjects of the
withdrawal of subjects on  which there has
been no progress since
December and even on which there has
been no negotiation for the moment and
that worries me
I hope that on the basis of a
legal text draft  draft
withdrawal treaty we will be able to
move forward more easily and finally this mad draft
text will conclude will contain our text on the
transition on the duration of this
transition
we have logically proposed that
it end on December 31, 2020 at the same
time as the multi-annual period
budget, the United Kingdom
seems to us to want to keep
this duration open, which is not possible on the
treatment of citizens' rights,
there too it  there is a divergence we would
like citizens arriving
before the appearance and during the post-
transition to be treated in the same
way there is also a divergence on
the possibility of opting in matters of
justice and internal affairs and on
international agreements and on  the
United Kingdom's participation in the committee
of experts and finally on the consultation mechanisms,
for example during the
transition period
concerning fisheries or
foreign and defense policy, so there are a
lot of differences